hospitalier de l'Université
de Montréal.
Bonsoir Dr Tremblay.
- Vous en pensez quoi de cette
nouvelle approche VID,
terminé la recommandation
d'isolement de cinq jours.
- En fait, ce n'est pas comme ça
compris le message
de la santé publique. dit c'esta
fièvre, de la toux, des
symptômes grippaux qui peuvent
être soient la COVID, soitl'infà
la maison. Le temps que dure le
groupe des symptômes.Ce qui estt
l'isolement. Autrement dit,
si les symptômes se résorbent,
on peut vaquer à nous
occupation il ne s'agit pas de
dire que ce n'est moins.
Important de s'isoler,
au contraire, cette
recommandation la reste,
c'est la question de la durée de
cinq jours. Si que
ça pourrait être inq de
la personne de se dire :
j'ai passé à travers la plus
grosse pvailler un peu,
mais je me protège je protège
les eaux
- Mais Docteur Boileau disait,
si vous n'allez pas bien vous
rester on, vous isolez.
Donc ça veut dire aussi question
mes on pourrait décider de
sortir.
- Personne n'a jamais fait laous
s'il restait vraiment cinq joure
changera pas grand-chose.
L'importance de conscientiser
les gens à savoir pourquoi ils
font les choses et qu'il effaces
gens et qu'on n'en croise des
gens qui nous tous en pleine
face ce n'est pas responsable.
gens que peu importe le virus
respiratoire qu'on a,
que ce soit l'influenza,
le RSV ou la COVID elle-même
précaution. On se base sur les
symptômes que l'
- C'est ça qui estiiiiiiii
c'est convient d'élargir peu
importe le virus, si ne vousà la
maison. Après, vous êtes quand
même c
occupations vous portez un
masque. ent la COVID
19 un rhumes ou l'influenza.va e
nombre d'infections qu'on dans .
- Si effectivement les gensles .
Les gens immuno supprimaient
porter le masque dans lescombine
fois-ci.
- L'influenza va venir très
rapidement C.
- Oui, on s'attend une saison
prématurée. C'est ce qui a été
expérimenté dans les pays de
l'hémisphère sud. Dans les deux
dernières années où on avait
déconfinement et dssssssssssssss
étaient très prudents
on ne transmettait pas aucun
virus relet, est-ce
qu'on a appris quelque chose de
it qu'on ait quand on  quand ons
symptômes, on ne se mêle pas aur
notre maladie.
- Peu importe finalement.Est-cee
utiles dans les circonstances?-e
que si on a la COVIDil y a des n
peut recevoir. Dans certaines
catégories d'âge, certaines
conditions, si on a des mala
qu'on peut avoir qui va nous
aider à avoir une maladie grave
doit être hospitalisé.
C'est encore très importan
réduire les hospit
On a 1900 personnes, 50
personnes en soins intensifs de
la COVID et c'est comme si
on a une
pas capable de l'absorber.
- L'autre recommandation qui a'e
l'an dernier on se souvient que
le gouvernement était engagété t
pas vacciné et qui refusait de.e
personnel n'est plus tenu d'être
vacciné. Vous en dites quoi?
- Je pense qu'on a manqué unecae
chose de bien, le problème qui
les rats personne, il n'était
pas nombreux à refuser la
population, ils avaient déjà un
contrat avec l'hôpital danslesqé
qu'il devait être vacciné contre
la COVID parce que ça n'existait
pas. Mais il faut se rappeler
que quand on travaille dans un
hôpital en acné
l'hépatite, la polio, nos
vaccins habituels. Ce n'est pas
extraordinaire de demander la
vexation personnelle de la
santé. Je pense qu'on se prive
d'un outil en disant aux
employés qu'ils avaient partis
du contrat comme les autres
vaccins qu'on demande recevoir.
Je ne partage pas la position de
la santé publique.
e
tous ces nouvelles
recommandations auront comme
impact sur le système
hospitalier?
- Si elles sont comprisesdans le
vigilance par rapport à
l'ensemble des virus
respiratoire et donc on doit
être d'autant plus prudent quand
on a des symptômes, s'isoler
temps qu'on a des symptômes et
porter le masque dans les lieux
publics ça devrait nous aider à
contrôler la situation. Si c'est
perçu que l'isolement n'est plus
obligatoire pour cinq jours,
les travers de la
plus besoin de vacciné, c'est
complètement opposé du message
que l'on veut envoyer.
On veut envoyer un signal
d'alarme parce que les nouveaux
variants arrivent, pluri
applicatif encore, plus
contagieux, deux autres virus
encore, les hospitalisations
vont augmenter.
Un nouveaux variants émergents
et double à chaque semaine en
termes de prendre la part du
marché des virus il est plus
contagieux que le BA 5.
Il a une tendance à échapper à
notre système immunitaire. Çanoé
ne nous protège pas, ça nous
protège, mais plus le virus
échappe à notre système
immunitaire moins la protectionn
danger notre système de santé.
Après donc se transmettre de
plus en plus au cours deses sem.
Merci d'avoir été là ce so